I'm in Paris for the first time again
for movies
yeah and so I was in like one of those
cool Tom Ford dresses with the Zips and
everything and um sure I saw Francis
Ford Coppola so I I was like oh so I
debated the whole time like do I go up
to him do I go and then finally I was
like I have to or oh we're good for the
rest I was at a restaurant at a
restaurant in Paris and he's at a giant
group of people and they take out most
of I mean it's a huge table of people
and I started walking and I noticed I
was barefoot but I was like oh maybe
they probably won't notice and so I'm
Barefoot and but I like introduced to
myself and I was like such a huge fan of
the law and like went on and then
introduced myself to the whole table hi
I'm Jennifer Lawrence they had no idea
who I was uh went back to the table my
entire dress was unzipped and my thong
was out
all right
so I was barefoot and my whole ass was
out
[Applause]